If you're impressed by the
dragons on the new "Game of
Thrones" prequel "House of the Dragon,"
get ready: a bigger beast is on its way.
Showrunners have promised that we'll
see at least 17 dragons in total,
including at least 9 in the first season. Two
episodes into the buzzy new show's first season,
audiences have already met a few massive
dragons, including Syrax and Caraxes,
who belong to Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen
and Prince Daemon Targaryen, respectively.
We've also heard about Balerion, the Black Dread,
whose skull now rests in the cellars of the Red
Keep, and Dreamfyre, whose egg was chosen for
Rhaenyra's late brother, then stolen by Daemon.
However, according to a fascinating tidbit
mentioned by the young Lady Laena Velaryon,
there's another, way bigger dragon
lurking somewhere out in the world.
"Do you know where Vhagar is now?"
"The dragon keepers believe she made home
somewhere on the coast of the Narrow Sea."
As audiences prepare to see a legendarily
large Chekhov's dragon show up,
some people might be asking: what's the deal with
this dragon, a massive female steed named Vhagar?
In the original book series by George R. R.
Martin, "A Song of Ice and Fire," Vhagar is
mentioned briefly by Tyrion Lannister,
and her basic stats are pretty intense.
For starters, Tyrion notes that Vhagar is so
massive that a soldier could easily ride a
horse down her throat. Martin writes in "A
Game of Thrones" that Tyrion knew Vhagar's
size because he saw her skull up close,
as Cersei saw Balerion's in Season 7:
"Tyrion had stood between their gaping jaws,
wordless and awed. You could have ridden a
horse down Vhaghar's gullet, although
you would not have ridden it out again."
In "A Clash of Kings," Martin writes that Vhagar's
breath was "so hot that it could melt a
knight's armor and cook the man inside."
So what is Vhagar's importance to the
"Game of Thrones" prequel? In Episode 2,
King Viserys tells Lady Laena that he's not
100% sure where Vhagar is at the moment,
but confirms that she's far too large to reside
in the dragon pits of King's Landing anyway.
"But Vhagar still lives, somewhere.
But too large for the Dragon Pit…"
"Some would say too large for our world."
While it's unsettling that Viserys
and his advisors seem to have,
you know, lost track of an enormous
fire-breathing murder machine,
there's little doubt that Vhagar will appear
in the series eventually. Some fans think this
dragon, from the "Fire Will Reign" teaser, is
Vhagar, but that hasn't been confirmed yet.
Martin's books also tell us that Vhagar was
almost as large as Balerion, and was ridden
by one of King Aegon's sister-wives, Visenya,
during Aegon's Conquest — the continent-conquering
campaign that made House Targaryen what it is
during the events of "House of the Dragon."
"I'm worried for all of us. They
say every time a Targaryen is born,
the gods toss a coin and the
world holds its breath."﻿
To say much more about Vhagar's role in "Fire &
Blood" — the source material for "House of the
Dragon" — would probably spoil upcoming episodes.
But it's safe to say that Vhagar — the biggest
living dragon in the world — is out there,
certain to swoop in at a critical moment.